it only took a matter of minutes after
england's heartbreaking defeat
to remind us of the ugly side of
football
many came out to condemn the racist
abuse england players marcus rashford
jaden sancho and bakayo sakura received
after missing penalties
but very few have been in their boots
patrice evra is recognized as one of the
best left backs
of his generation
a golden career with manchester united
and as the french national team captain
saw him lift countless trophies but he
says
his toughest competition has been racism
in the game he loves
football you know is a joy to watch and
he brings a lot of emotion and when
people are disappointed
you can feel the hate the hate comes out
really strongly then people
and i don't know why instead of saying
like
oh he's such a bad player he shouldn't
miss a penalty
they involve you know your religion your
color
so when you saw the abuse or heard about
the abuse that these
boys were receiving and as a black
player who's
lived and played in england at the top
club in the world
how does that make you feel seeing that
it was painful to watch
and especially you know those kids you
know they may be not stronger
as other person and it is not fair
i wasn't surprised uh
i feel it is disgusting and those people
have to be ashamed of themselves because
also they bring so much
shame in the country of england evra 2
was at the receiving end of racism
on and off the pitch but believes this
kind of discrimination
in english football is the worst it's
ever been
why do you think the situation in terms
of racism in english football
is worse now than it was
say 10 years ago when you were playing
here first of all i think uh
social media have increased i think the
platform they should do
something more than that because of
course you can delay the comment
they can block people and everything but
i'm sorry when it's like a coveted
new straight away you get like the flag
in any social media when it's about a
nudity
they can ban it straight away those
platforms
they allowed those people to spread the
racism
so don't tell me they can't do anything
before england even started their euros
campaign there were divisions amongst
fans
over players taking the knee a stance
evra supports
even though he says it's not enough do
you think
english football can move forward do you
think it can ever fully stamp out racism
it will always be there because he's
been there for so many years
let's stop saying just in england
everywhere every
single country if we don't do something
investment towards educating fans is
whatevra thinks will work
to minimize racial hate but even a
footballing legend
optimistic and hopeful of change thinks
without
it racism will plague this much-loved
sport
forever in zaman rashid sky news
manchester